hi guys i'm abby sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen I don't know about you but it
feels kind of like weight loss has
become a bit taboo and this new year
my whole YouTube and Instagram feed has
been full of people promising ways to
get rid of bloating so it's almost like
every Wellness influencer I've review is
going off about how to wake up with a
flat tummy and improve your digestion to
stop the bloat and since there seems to
be no shortage of information a lot of
air quotes going on here but I want to
make sure that you are getting the facts
there also seems to be a lot of
questions from a lot of you about
bloating specifically in the context of
a vegan diet so today I want to discuss
bloating in general whether a vegan diet
is potentially to blame and of course
how I'm seeing the quest for better
digestion maybe getting co-opted by diet
culture to get some greater insight on
the topic we'll also be joined by
registered dietician and gut health
expert Andrea Hardy so stay tuned for a
little bit later in this video for that
and also don't forget to check out my
new merch line I've got the link in the
description this is my saucy shirt
because I'm feeling a little saucy today
but you can check out all of the options
and all of the great shirts and
sweatshirts right there now first of all
what is bloating now bloating is
described as the feeling of abdominal
pressure or feeling tight and swollen in
the abdominal area now with bloating you
often see an increase in abdominal size
in a very short period of time hence why
of course all of these wellness bloggers
are trying to get rid of it ultimately
it kind of makes you feel and look
bigger in the waist area then you maybe
want to look and feel now bloating is
often accompanied by several other
not-so-nice symptoms things like
abdominal pain gas burping belching
abdominal rumbling or the gurgles I am
sure one time or another you have all
probably felt bloated I mean I do all
the time but it's super common with
being reported in 20% to 30% of the
general population on top of that more
than 50% of people with bloating report
that it has a significant impact on
their quality of life so yeah this is
not just a vanity thing it can actually
legitimately
hurt so what causes bloating well there
are a variety of factors that can cause
bloating but a lot of the time the
common cause involves gas so reason
number one excessive gas in your
digestive tract so gas buildup in the
digestive tract can occur if undigested
food gets broken down or when you
swallow air so while everyone of course
swallows air when they eat or drink some
people can actually just swallow an
excessive amount which can cause of
course a lot of discomfort number two
constipation when people are constipated
that build up a fecal matter can mimic
the pain and pressure of bloating so
when stool gets stuck in our colon we
produce more gas and that inability to
clear gas can produce a significant
amount of pressure on our abdomen
number three uncoordinated abdominal
wall muscles now aside from gas or
constipation another common cause of
bloating may actually have to do with a
muscular issue when we eat our diaphragm
typically needs to move up to
accommodate your stretch stomach if
there's an issue with your abdominal
muscles it may not be able to
accommodate your stretch stomach
triggering bloating and abdominal pain
now there's also a lot of medical causes
of bloating so I'll just touch on some
of the more common ones number one small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth aka SIBO
now Sasebo is a condition where patients
develop excessive amounts of bacteria
and their small bowel leading to severe
bloating and distension SIBO is a really
common topic amongst wellness bloggers
with a lot of people claiming that IBS
doesn't exist and then it's all really
just SIBO this apparently comes for
studies that overstate the rates of SIBO
in IBS with some studies suggesting up
to 80 percent of IBS cases having SIBO
while SIBO does actually exist at the
moment we just don't have a fantastic
way to diagnose it yet in
clinical cases where SIBO is identified
it can be managed through a combination
of dietary changes and antibiotics
number two functional gastrointestinal
disorders aka FG ids so functional
gastrointestinal disorders which is not
only a mouthful but there's a lot to
talk about here are ultimately disorders
that affect any part of the
gastrointestinal tract from the
esophagus to the intestines now some
common functional gastrointestinal
disorders include internal bowel
syndrome and dyslexia so all of these
conditions carry symptoms of abdominal
cramping and discomfort gas and bloating
in fact bloating has been reported in up
to 96 percent of patients with IBS
primary features of FG ids are abdominal
motility high nerve sensitivity and
brain gut dysfunction next let's talk
about structural gastrointestinal
disorders so structural gastrointestinal
sorters occur when the structure of the
digestive tract looks abnormal and does
not work properly as a result let's talk
about some of the more common ones first
celiac disease now we've talked quite a
bit about celiac disease and gluten
intolerance in my toilet-table series so
if you haven't already you can check out
that playlist right here
celiac disease is a digestive disorder
caused by an abnormal immune reaction to
gluten basically your body responds to
gluten as a toxin which destroys the
villi which are found on the wall to
small intestines when the villi get
damaged the body is unable to absorb
nutrients from food which can cause
permanent intestinal damage and health
complications common symptoms of celiac
disease include abdominal bloating and
pain another example is inflammatory
bowel disease so inflammatory bowel
disease aka IBD is described as a group
of conditions where the lining of the
digestive tract is inflamed the two main
forms of IBD are Crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis in Crohn's disease
inflammation can occur anywhere along
the digestive tract however usually it's
located in the lower part of the small
bowel and the upper colon in ulcerative
colitis inflammation typically occurs
only in the large intestine including
the rectum and the anus again both main
form
of IBD can cause bloating and gas but
now what about healthy people just
trying to be more healthy can a vegan
diet cause bloating with the onion
movement spreading across YouTube many
youtubers that used to be vegan claim
that a vegan diet caused Gus issues
disturbances and bloating I want to
explore some of the most common reasons
why that might be number one a vegan
diet is typically high in fiber now a
vegan diet typically has lots of fruits
veggies beans and legumes all of which
happened to be really high in fiber
while fiber is so important for keeping
us regular and carry numerous other
health benefits a diet that's too rich
in fiber may of course cause a lot of
bloating people that initially
transition to a vegan or vegetarian diet
tend to report a lot of unpleasant gut
issues like constipation bloating or
diarrhea while these symptoms tend to go
away after a few weeks or months as the
body gets used to the uptake in fiber
some people experience those symptoms
chronically this is likely not because
of the diet per se unless you're
consuming an excessive amount of fiber
consistently but there may also be other
underlying causes for their bloating
another potential culprit is FODMAPs
now if you've heard about bloating
you've probably also heard about FODMAPs
or a low fodmap diet so for a more
detailed breakdown on FODMAPs
definitely check out my whole video on
FODMAPs in my toilet talk series right
here but basically FODMAPs
stands for and it's big fermentable
oligo die monosaccharides and polyols so
these are a group of short-chain
carbohydrates that are often associated
with digestive symptoms like gas
bloating diarrhea and constipation
because they are often difficult to
break down and they tend to be kind of
poorly absorbed in the small intestine
because FODMAPs are poorly absorbed they
sit in the small bowel and intestine
where they're fermented and produce
excess gas eventually leading to
bloating gas and stomach pain fodmap
compounds draw water into the small
intestine and that water in the
digestive tract can cause feelings of
pressure
and fullness around the abdomen so how
does this relate to a vegan diet well a
vegan diet tends to be rich in fruits
vegetables legumes pulses grains and
fauna are found almost exclusively in
plant foods with the exception of
lactose and dairy products so here are
some common Fahd not foods which may be
often found in the vegan diet wheat so
breads pasta breakfast cereals etc
grains like amaranth barley things like
that garlic onion hi pod not fruits like
apples apricots cherries peaches figs
mangoes watermelon - not vegetables so
things like asparagus
Brussels sprouts cauliflower leaks
mushrooms and snow peas also legumes and
pulses so think about things like
black-eyed peas chickpeas kidney beans
lentils and split peas as well as common
sweeteners like agave nectar sugar-free
mints or chewing gums so when it comes
to FODMAPs some individuals are just
more sensitive than others in which case
specific fodmap compounds tend to need
to be eliminated from their diet now
let's talk about some of the dietary
changes that may be recommended for
treating bloating starting with a low
fodmap diet trial now a low fodmap diet
has been confirmed as the most effective
therapy for managing IBS and other gut
related disorders it's definitely been
effective at decreasing symptoms in at
least 75 percent of patients
now according to studies fodmap
restriction resulted in a fifty to
eighty two percent reduction in bloating
this is a diet that would really require
the support of a dietitian because
you're not to cut out the high thought
nut foods forever it's really a trial
and error situation where we would
really be looking at introducing each of
the fodmap groups back in in various
quantities to determine the offending
foods and the tolerated amounts in the
context of a vegan diet
this may mean removing certain - not
fruits and vegetables wheat products
legumes and pulses etc until you can
determine the real true source of the
problem another suggestion is to
increase or decrease fiber so
manipulating fiber
maybe an important first step if you're
struggling with constant bloating
if constipation is your Associated
symptom increasing your fiber intake may
be an effective strategy to really help
you get things moving in the bowels and
to reduce bloating but if you've got
underlying causes of bloating like IBS
or IBD increasing fiber may actually
worsen symptoms because fiber is often
fermentable meaning that it can increase
gas production and contribute to
bloating so this is why it's always
really important to work with a
registered dietician and doctor to
understand your unique case number three
cut back on gas since bloating is often
associated with excess gas aka air in
the digestive tract it's recommended
that people avoid carbonated drinks and
that will help prevent the intake of
even more air chewing gum or drinking
out of a straw can also cause you to
swallow more air which again can get
trapped in the gut another suggestion is
cooking foods there is some evidence
that cooking certain vegetables that are
rich in FODMAPs like broccoli
cauliflower cabbage and Brussels sprouts
can make it easier for them to digest
essentially cooking foods will break
down some of the undigestible fibers and
make it easier for your body to process
so when you're feeling bloated avoiding
a lot of raw vegetables definitely does
make sense
finally let's touch on some other
lifestyle changes and medications for
treating bloating first of all move your
body moving your body is agreement and
naturally get things moving in your gap
by improving gas clearance from the
bowel one study for example found that
using a stationary bike improved
intestinal gas clearance and reduce
symptoms of bloating number two stress
relieving activities
aside from food another cause of
digestive issues is stress so reducing
stress may play a role in reducing
bloating symptoms a lot of people
suffering from IBS find that it flares
up in times of stress and research has
found that diaphragmatic breathing
techniques may help reduce abdominal
distension another recommendation is
antibiotics in some cases antibiotics
may be appropriate in the manage of
certain conditions like small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth aka
seabone for SIBO management an on
systemic antibiotic like for fact cement
is used where it remains in the gut
without spreading to other areas of the
body
another potential option is
antidepressants believe it or not in
some studies antidepressants were
effective at reducing bloating while
honestly other studies have found no
effect it's still ultimately unclear
whether they are effective at treating
bloating but it's definitely something
that I personally am keeping an eye on
in the literature we also should talk
about digestive enzymes now if you're
having trouble breaking down certain
carbohydrates your doctor may recommend
digestive enzyme however currently there
really is little evidence that
combination digestive enzymes that is
not traditional digestive enzymes like
Beano or lacked a for example are really
helpful for people with common gut
problems like heartburn or IBS there
have been cases where a digestive
enzymes have been effective at reducing
bloating but for now the research is
ultimately conflicting at best I also
want to flag that a lot of the
over-the-counter digestive enzymes have
not been regulated or scientifically
evaluated for effectiveness so I would
definitely caution their use and always
speak to a doctor before shelling out
the cash for these supplements so to
understand the association between a
vegan diet and bloating and provides
some non-diet ways to address bloating
I'm joined by registered dietician and
gut health expert
Andrea Hardy so thank you so much for
joining me Andrea thanks for having me
I'm really excited to be talking about
this topic amazing now the phrase I feel
bloated it seems like that's the new I
feel fat so why why do you think this
kind of new bloating trend is happening
and why is that a problem right so I
think there's a really big interesting
digestive health driving the interest
and the awareness around how our bodies
change in our bodies bloat throughout
the day
I think a lot of people are starting to
increase their intake of different
fibers maybe some different fats and
that in itself can also contribute to
this bloating as well I think with the
interest in having a thin body people do
really take notice and are hyper aware
of how their bodies expand throughout
the day and then kind of contract over
nights leading to a lot of fixation on
how their bodies look hmm
so true I mean we see so much and so
many people talking on Instagram and
YouTube about you know waking up with a
flat stomach for example so from your
experience how do you determine when
it's a gut issue or a body issue and how
would that impact your treatment yeah so
I think it's a really important question
to discuss about how people feel about
their bodies and how they feel about the
bloating typically bloating can be a
concern if it's accompanied with a lot
of pain as well as a change in bowel
habits whether that's constipation or
diarrhea those would be a few things I
would consider making a change in diet
for I think it's important to also tease
out you know what sort of expectations
they have around their body's changing a
lot of people think that they should be
you know going out throughout the day
with those flat of a tummy as they
started with and that just doesn't make
space for food or fermentation which is
a good thing mm-hmm
oh yeah so interesting and so you know I
totally agree I think that that's become
the real issue so when you have a new
patient in your in your office that may
be experiencing some bloating is there
any kind of screening that has to happen
for disordered eating before you are
addressing any of those kind of bloating
or digestive concerns absolutely so we
screen all of our patients for
disordered eating behavior as well as
body image issues so really important
questions around their history and
relationship with food how they behave
in certain food situations how
catastrophic
three pounds would be all of those sorts
of validated screening tools along with
a couple other questions that help me to
elucidate how they relate to food in
their bodies so if it is the end of the
world to their self-esteem and
self-worth that they get bloated
throughout the day that's a red flag
that this could be something more to do
with body image issues rather than bloat
not always because it is you know
difficult if you're dealing with
bloating dissension and pain however we
want to really tease that out yeah
absolutely I think that's a really
important piece okay so a lot of my
viewers are plant-based and I'm curious
in your experience so why is the vegan
diet often associated with good gut
health and on the flip side while a
vegan diet may be able to kind of
benefit our gut can it harm it like is
there a link between a vegan diet and
some of these bloating and other
digestive issues for sure so a lot of
people are very interested in going
vegan and as a gut health dietician the
reason I see most often is for digestive
health interestingly when we look at all
of the research together what we see is
that a vegan got microbiota that's the
bacteria in your gut and almond omnivore
got microbiota isn't really that
different what really differentiates a
person's got microbiota from one person
to another is variety and fiber so you
can be healthy if you eat meat and you
can be healthy if you eat vegan even the
the key thing is actually getting enough
fiber and enough variety there was a
really cool research project the citizen
science project it was about 15,000
participants and they compared people
that had about 30 different plant-based
foods a week as opposed to a group of
people that had 10 or less so this is a
variety marker and a fiber marker and
those people that were getting that 30
different plant-based foods a week had a
more abundant gut microbiota and a
greater variety of bacteria in their gut
which are markers that we use to measure
a healthy gut microbiota on the mmm-hmm
nope sorry continue on the flip side of
things the vegan diet can also you know
add a little bit of digestive distress
to your tummy and the reason for that is
a lot of times when people decide to go
vegan it's all or nothing you know
balls-to-the-wall
yeah so I find that people go from you
know a moderate or even low fiber diet
to a very high fiber diet which is
really hard on your stomach it can cause
a lot of bloating gas distension as well
as constipation or diarrhea and so
backed-up bloating is absolutely a thing
if you pack your body too full of fiber
and your body can't process and handle
that fiber you can get really
constipated and feel very uncomfortable
which is why adding in fiber nice and
slow is really important so if you had a
client or patient who was trying to you
know go vegan is there any strategies or
recommendations that you would have in
terms of how to slowly incorporate those
plant-based foods while still of course
making sure that they're getting all the
nutrients that they need yeah absolutely
so the biggest thing is a nice slow
progress so swapping out I would pretty
do the transition a little bit more
slowly and kind of do a swap this for
that so let's start swapping out one or
two animal products each you know a few
days until we end up you know fully
vegan at the same time it's really
important to understand people's
motivations for going vegan if it's for
gut health as we previously discussed
maybe they don't need to be so extreme
hmm yeah I think that's all really
really important and I think yes in this
world as we both know people love the
extremes and so it really does come back
to listening to your body and and really
ultimately doing what feels best and if
going from you know 15 grams of fiber to
50 grams of fiber doesn't feel good
from you know in a few days then it
might be worth kind of scaling back and
and doing it in a more slow fashion so I
think glad that you brought that up so
let's talk about kind of intuitive
eating and a non diet approach to kind
of gut health so how would you support a
patient through ultimately restrictive
diet like a low fodmap elimination diet
without putting them at risk for
disordered eating especially if maybe
they already have a bit of a history of
disordered eating or kind of disorderly
behaviors absolutely so anytime anybody
has any gut symptoms usually our first
go-to is looking at food and with that a
lot of times people come to me already
with a lot of fear around eating because
digestive disorders like IBS involve the
gut brain connection a lot of times
people are nervous to eat which then can
precipitate digestive symptoms so when
it comes to a restrictive diet this can
actually do more harm than good
so it's really important even though the
low fodmap diet is thought about is not
elimination diet to do more of a swap
this for that so really taking a look at
the big picture seeing what people eat
and swap out those higher fodmap items
for lower fodmap foods if somebody has a
history of disordered eating or eating
disorder behavior the low fodmap diet
may actually not be appropriate at all
or there's something now called the
gentle fodmap diet where we remove some
of those really - map foods and swap
them out with lower ones without
restricting all sources of loudmouths so
those are a couple different options we
can do to help make sure that it doesn't
feel like a diet and it doesn't feel
restrictive I think it's important that
people look at the low fodmap diet as a
short-term diet to really understand
what triggers their symptoms as opposed
to this long term restrictive diet that
they need to stay on forever because
it's just not the approach we should
take I agree and I think that needs to
be kind of reinforced also you know in
the media and online on social media
because I always worry that I mean the
low fodmap diet if you were to restrict
or cut out all foods that are high on
the - app list
you're looking at a very very small
potentially small amount of food once
you actually also factor in food
preferences and things like that but
like you said in a traditional sense the
low fodmap elimination diet is is meant
as a short form kind of almost like a
process like like a test that you would
do with registered dietitians so that
you can identify the exact culprits not
to necessarily have to cut out all of
those foods in complete quantities for
the rest of your life so I always worry
that people think about the low-fat the
you know fodmap diet and they think
they're almost using it as a way to kind
of justify their restrictions so and is
that something that yeah is that
something you've seen fodmap lifestyle
fodmap is not a lifestyle it's a very
short-term diet two to six weeks max and
always a dietician supervision so yeah
it's really challenging so I see a lot
of vloggers you know I live little
fodmap well that's really not the best
approach and when we think of what
FODMAPs do in our gut they ferment they
feed bacteria and the low fodmap diet
doesn't offer variety so really we're
doing a detriment to our gut health when
we follow the low fodmap diet long term
which you know kind of circumvents what
people are actually working towards yeah
I'm so glad that you brought that up I
think that that piece alone is going to
be so so valuable now last question do
you've any kind of non diet strategies
for people to address their bloating if
they want to incorporate a plant-based
lifestyle for sure
so as you're starting to incorporate
more plant-based foods inherently
choosing some of those lower bought mat
plant-based foods are a great option so
things like canned rinsed drained
lentils or chickpeas are probably a
better place to start than black beans
that you cook yourself because they're
gonna be lower in FODMAPs
other things that work really well for
managing IBS and bloating it is actually
small frequent meals
your food well and slowing down and
enjoying it because we can swallow a lot
of air when we're eating talking and
getting busy other things that can help
are things like yoga and movement that
helps to get your digestive tract moving
passing gas you're experiencing and then
if you need further help talking with
your dietitian doctor or pharmacist
about some non pharmacological ways to
help manage some of those symptoms that
don't involve dietary restriction for
example peppermint oil capsules have
been shown to help reduce bloating gas
and abdominal pain as well as certain
digestive enzymes like lactaid which
helps to break down lactose or something
like you know or be no cyst which helps
to break down galacto oligosaccharides
so those sorts of things are some non
pharmacological diet of non
pharmacological approaches that don't
involve nutrition restriction I love
that I love that well thank you so much
Andrea for sharing your insights with me
I always learn so much from just
watching her your Instagram and
following along on your journey so I'm
gonna be leaving all of Andrea's handles
and websites so that you can get in
touch with her if you're looking for
someone to work one-on-one especially
when it comes to digestive health so
thank you so much Andrea thanks for
having me
all right bye so friends I hope that
that was informative and enlightening I
know that I personally learned a lot so
if you loved this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with any questions around bloating
or your experience with bloating what
works for you what maybe hasn't worked
for you don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]